وصلت قوات فاجنر انسحابها والعوده الى
قواعدها من مقاطعات روسيه بموجب وساطه قام
بها الرئيس بيلاروسي الكساد لوكاشينكو هذا
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
حيثيات وتفاصيل التفاهمات التي جرت بين
الجانبين والى اي مدى اثنت الاحداث على
صوره روسيا وهل عكست صراعا داخليا على
السلطه والنفوذ ما الابعاد الخارجيه
للازمه والسوناريو التي انتهت اليه
[موسيقى]
الان لدينا هذا الاتفاق ولكن اتفاق قصير
المدى هناك الكثير من الشك فيما يتعلق
بتفاصيل هذا الاتفاق فعلى سبيل المثال كم
عدد كم عدد مرتزقه عددهم حوالي 25 الف
واكثر كم منهم سيد حقول وزاره الدفاع
ويضمون الجيش النظامي اذا كل ما لدينا لحد
الان هو مجرد فتره التنفس
وراحت حلفاء روسيا اثار توترا او نوعا من
التنافس بين الرئيس في كازاخستان الرئيس
البيولوسي الذي نجحت وسلطته قاديروف في
منطقه الشيشان كان هناك
نفسه اضطر الى ظهور وتوعد من يتمر
[موسيقى]
د
هذا هو الصراع على السلطه على النفوذ وليس
صراع لحل محل بوتين بل هو محاوله امسيت هو
المستشار اكثر اهميه للسيد بوتين ولا
اعتقد ان هذا القتال وهذه المنافسه قد
انتهت
وفي صبغه اصطناعيه نوعا ما نعم مبدا
الاساسي وكان ومازال العداله الاجتماعيه
ولكن هي كواجهه اما ما هو عن اشياء مخفيه
في هذه المسيره او في هذا التمرد انا
متاكده انه هناك سرعات ما بين مجموعات
مختلفه
وهذا الشيء ليست له حتى علاقه
بالعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا من الواضح
ان ما جرى كان
تصعيدا كبيرا يظهر عدم قدره الدوله
المركزيه على فرض خطوتها وسيادتها الكامله
في بلد شاسع جغرافيا وكبير ديموغرافيا
يظهر ان ميليشيا نشات وترعرعت في كنف
السلطه انما ظلت متمايزه عن الجيش عن
المؤسسات الامنيه الرسميه مجرد قيام هذا
التمرد يظهر ضعفا في اداره البلاد وقد
يشجع انواع اخرى من التمرد في مرحله لاحقه
[موسيقى]
نعرف المطلب الاساسي لسيد بريجوجل وهي
اقاله وزير الدفاع
[موسيقى]
السيد السيد
هو سياسي مخضرم وكان يعتبر ومازال يعتبر
من قبل بعض الناس خليفه رقم الاول للرئيس
بوتين فيما بعد كما يبدو هناك مجموعات لا
تريد ان تروا في هذا
المنصب كخليفه اذا صح التعبير المؤامره
بان الغرب هو خلف القامه والتمرد اقامه
الدليل عليه وليس هناك دليل بان هذا عمل
نظمه واتفق عليه سيد بوتين مع السيد
مشاهده الاجهزه الروسيه مقبله على صدامات
داخليه يشجع اطراف خارجيه على الدخول في
مفاوضات على من يمكن ان يلعب دوره لفهم
الواقع اكثر للتاثير في الواقع لكن هناك
بلا شك خشيه عالميه وليس فقط غربيه من
اللا استقرار في روسيا لانها بلد نووي لان
فيها منشات عسكريه خطيره جدا لانه من
المفيد ان يبقى هناك سلطه مركزيه يمكن
للتفاوض معها